good see you how are you
[Music]
do
I've
already
[Music]
thing
welcome
well
seats
please
[Music]
did
water
e
the house will come to H to order the
chair recognizes a member from marburn
representative Osburn who moves at the
house adjourn from the session of June
29th 2023 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay you guys have it in the house is
adjourned house will attend to a Prayer
by house chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart
pastor of St Paul's United Methodist
Manchester good morning
God good morning Mr
Speaker good morning House of
Representatives let us be in a spirit of
prayer the psalmus wrote in Psalm
4610 be still and know that I am
God we live in a noisy world a world
filled with
distractions
frustrations and
complications but if we allow the
distractions of a world in on
occasion so that we can be in a faithful
relationship with you oh
God we live in a violent world where
there is hatred and
War amongst
countries God help us all to be still so
we can feel your love and your peace in
our
lives God be with all the people that
have been
affected by
War be with the people of
Israel the people of
Gaza the people of
Palestine the people of
Ukraine the people of
Russia and be with us as
well we are all children of God help us
to be mindful that of that and when we
do we find and experience your
peace we need to be still and turn to
you oh
God God I ask you to bring us blessing
to this New Hampshire House of
Representatives today as they revisit
previous
legislation and complete their final
work
today bless each of these hardworking
Representatives as they work so
diligently throughout the year to do
their best for those they
represent we pray all this to your glory
oh God that through your grace we will
receive the gifts of of your vision your
listening ear your wisdom and your
guiding hand of leadership we need to do
the business presented before us
today in gratitude we pray and praise
amen chair recognizes a member from
Mason representative John L wikii who
will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Unice the chair now recognizes Brook
Mills of Bedford who will sing our
national
[Music]
anthem
by
the's
light what so
proudly
we had the Twilight last
gleaming who Ro stripes and bright
stars through the
per
fight or the r parts we
watch were so
Gallant
streaming and the rocket red glare the
bombs bursting in air gave proof through
the
night that our flag was still
there
sat that Star
Spangled
yet
[Music]
W the land of the
free and the
[Applause]
bra
the house will attend to request for Le
of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives buros filio McBeth Muse
Alexandra Murray Rulo the day important
business Representatives brewyard Connor
cordelli William Dolan levit lungren
Moffett Newton nter Palmer sandborne
sidel Juliet Smith verville Vincent and
Wallace the day illness in the family
Representatives hold and
panic these leaves of action shall be
granted unless otherwise hold there by
the house the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Stephanie and Frederick Ryan and
Patricia fsy parents and grandmother of
the singer guest of Representative
lungren Richard weer guest of
Representative selig Paige bman and
Kathleen Fountain guests of
Representative tersi Jim Raven guest of
Representative elberger and fourth grade
students from East Dairy Memorial guests
of Representative Steve Pearson they're
with us in the gallery
[Applause]
house
resolution Mr Speaker house resolution
18 whereas the New Hampshire House of
Representatives learned with great
sorrow of the attack against Israel on
October 7th 2023 by the terrorist
organization Hamas and whereas American
citizens were among the over 1,000
casualties of or hostages taken during
that attack and whereas a long-term plan
for Beast was being negotiated by many
states in the region that would avert
situations like this attack and its
future now remains in serious doubt and
whereas because of this attack further
Civ civilian casualties among Israelis
and Palestinians have
increased and whereas the New Hampshire
house has a long-standing history of
affirming its support for communities
States and Nations throughout the world
especially especially in times of
distress now therefore be it resolved
that the New Hampshire House of
Representatives honors the victims and
hostages of the Hamas attack and offers
its condolences to the loved ones and
families of the victims and be it
further resolved that the House of
Representatives in regular session
convened stands against terrorism
supports humanitarian aid for those
civilians caught amid conflict and hopes
for a lasting peace in the region
offered by the House of
Representatives would everybody please
rise for a moment of silence for what
happened overseas and for what happened
Communications Mr Speaker communication
dated July 5th 2023 Dear Mr clerk owing
to the continuing failure to provide a
remote option or indeed any option so as
to permit the continued performance of
my legislative duties in the fact that
ongoing litigation as the date not
provided any indication of when or if
any relief might be forthcoming I cannot
allow my constituents to continue
indefinitely with a fewer than three
Representatives accordingly I hereby
resign the office of Representative to
the general court effective immediately
permit me to take this opportunity to
thank all members of the legislative
staff for their many kindnesses to me
over many years and to further Express
thanks and best wishes to my colleagues
in the continuance of their important
work and to my constituents for the
Decades of confidence they reposed in me
yours Fai Faithfully David Cody a letter
dated September 6
2023 dear Paul please be advised that
the following representative elect is
sworn into office by the governor and
executive Counsel on this day for
Grafton County District 16 David frock
to venfield sincerely David M scanland
Secretary of
house
further
Communications Mr Speaker a letter dated
September 18th 2023 dear speaker Packard
I am moving out of my residence in Coos
district 6 and with deep regret I write
to submit my resignation from the House
of Representatives it has been a great
honor and privilege to represent the
people of gorum and surrounding
communities for the past 17 years I wish
all of my house colleagues the best as
you continue your work serving the
people of New Hampshire Bill hatch Coos
County district 6 communication dated
September 19th 2023 dear speaker Packard
I write today to submit my resignation
from the house effective immediately
serving Lancaster and surrounding
communities in Coos County in the
legislature has been an honor to my
colleagues in the house it has been an
honor working with you to help make New
Hampshire a better place respectfully
submitted Troy mner Coos District 1 and
a letter dated October 4th 2023 dear
Paul please be advised that the
following representative elect was sworn
into office by the governor and Council
on this this day Rockingham County
District 1 Harold rafter of Nottingham
sincerely David M scanland Secretary of
[Applause]
house the house will attend to the
governor's veto message and House Bill
35 requiring student identification
cards to include the national Eating
Disorders
hotline the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's vetle
shall House Bill 35 become law the state
constitution requires a roll call 2third
veto members take your seats this will
them
order if you're in favor having the bill
become law you will press the green
button if you are propos and wish to
sustain the governor's vetle you will
press the red button voting stations
open
for
be
has everybody made sure your voting
on okay if you're in favor of having the
bill become law you will press the green
button if you oppose and wish to sustain
the governor's vle you'll press the red
seconds
s
Med
if all members present had an
opportunity to
sustained
house will be in
order the house will attend that the
governor's veto message on House Bill
142 relative to the operation of the
Burgess biop
plant the question before the house is
not withstanding the governor's VTO sh
no
Speaker I come before you today to
oppose the veto of HB 142 relative to
the operation of the Burgess biopower
Burgess biopower has been operating in
my hometown since 2013 and has been a
terrific corporate citizen of Berlin
it is New Hampshire's only remaining
biomass plant providing Renewable
baseload Power to eversource under a 20
20-year power purchase
agreement should this veto stand the
plant will close hundreds of people
could lose their jobs and New
Hampshire's Forest products industry
will be deal dealt a severe blow in what
will then be known as an unforced error
on the part of this
legislature to Reg the governor's veto
message you would think we were dealing
with a business that no one would miss
one that was poorly
run one that cost us more than it was
worth knowing the plant as I do I still
cannot understand the impetus for this
wrong-headed thinking it could not be
further from the
truth the governor says New Hampshire
rate payers have been taken for over
$200 million in subsidies for the
Burgess biomass plant
the fact is that burge's biopower power
purchase agreement with
eversource specifies what each megawatt
hour of power is worth and that is all
they have received in their 10 years
under this
agreement the New Hampshire Department
of energy completed an audit of Burgess
last year after we passed SB
271 in which they confirmed in which
they confirmed that no money beyond what
is allowed in the power purchase
agreement was paid to burges by rate
payers note however that biomass is a
renewable energy source so Burgess is
eligible for renewable energy credits
which are turned over to eversource per
New Hampshire
law and renewable energy credits do not
count as
subsidies the governor goes on to say
the power purchase agreement is an an
example of what can go wrong in the bi
when what can go wrong when government
is exploited by opportunists in the
private sector the governor is asking us
to blame an award-winning
state-of-the-art power plant who came to
us for help in which both the House and
Senate agreed that such help was
appropriate indeed
necessary in this case the problem with
the power purchase agreement came from
the New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission not the private sector New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
imposed a condition on the deal that
forced burges to carry the difference
between any lower price in the day ahead
energy market and the agreed upon
contract price in the power purchase
agreement as an obligation on the
company's books this imposition of a
paper debt burden to the plant's cost
structure changed the deal
marketly this paper debt is not an
operating cost of the
plan but a calculation that is carried
on the books but with an obligation to
pay if the amount exceeds a fixed
cap HB 142 as written and approved by us
this spring excuses the acred excess
amount the paper debt that Burg's
pay
the governor goes on to blame Burgess
biopower for taking too long to find a
long-term
solution but the long time that's
elapsed has been mostly on us Burgess
first came to us in 2017 when we passed
SB
577 Burgess could see that the
accumulating obligation on their books
was a compounding problem that they
could not fix that they could not fix it
without renegotiating the contract or OB
aining a waiver of the power purchase
agreement from lawmakers to eliminate
the paper
debt there is no truth to any rumor that
the debt is a result of how the plant is
run or that it has not operated to its
fullest
capability to date ever Source has not
been willing to come back to the table
to negotiate any change of the power
purchase
agreement whether Burgess continues in
operation with all of the benefits of
locally sourced renewable electric power
and the jobs that it brings to the New
Hampshire economy now Falls to us here
today to the
decide in 2018 we suspended the paper
debt for three years to provide time to
find a way forward and we should we
should have provided relief from the
accumulating obligation then but we did
not so in 2021 we passed s SP
271 uh to to forgive the accumulated
paper debt altogether but a house
Amendment modified that bill and delayed
forgiveness again until the New
Hampshire Department of energy could
complete an audit of burgess's
books the
results the results of the audit were
received in December
2022 and they concluded that the plant's
finances were in fact as presented by
Burgess and that the plant has been
operated to the highest professional
industry standards
with these results in hand HB 142 was
filed to finally give the plant the
solution it had originally sought we
voted 269 to 109 in favor of that relief
this past spring and the Senate vote
that followed was unanimous declaring
that passing this bill was the right
thing for New
Hampshire then came the V veto which
brings us to where we are
today I'll cut my remarks short here to
allow my uh fellow colleague from fellow
representative from burin
to carry on but let me make one more
comment before I step away from the
well burges biopower is good for the
economy Burg's bi biopower is good for
Berlin and the North country and Burgess
biopower is good for New Hampshire thank
you
the chair recognizes Edmund ke
Kelly thank you Mr
Speaker as my colleague alluded to in
the governor's veto message he blames
Burgess biopower for f taking too long
to find a long-term solution but finding
a solution has always been the
responsibility of this leg legislature
the reason it may seem that we have been
asked to vote on this so many times is
because we the legislature have
continued to Kick the Can down the road
each time we have voted for a suspension
it has delayed repayment but not AC
cruel of the
CRF last year when this legislature
voted to suspend the repayment for a
fifth year we did so with the
understanding that it would give the
department of energy time to complete a
full Financial audit of this facility
the agreement was that once we had that
audit in hand we would return with that
long-term solution the audit which was
exhaustive confirmed that the biomass
plant is one of the best in the country
and now we are back to give the governor
the long-term solution he has been
asking for as this bill was so expertly
amended by the chair of the house
science technology and energy committee
it only resets the Clock IT returns us
to that $100 million cap on the CRF and
puts the responsibility squarely on
Burgess for any F future acrs today we
vote on whether Burgess will continue to
operate November 1st when the current
suspension expires a lot has been made
about the benefit of the plant to the
forest Product Industry but the benefits
extend to every corner of this state the
mom and pop gas stations who provide
Fuel and food to the 100 plus truckers
Who deliver chips to the plant every day
the Family Farms in all 10 counties of
this state who receive low priced
fertilizer made from the nutrient Rich
fly ash that it comes exclusively from
this plant The Machinist the
electricians the pipe fitters none of
whom are directly employed by Burgess
but can rely on the plant for regular
business let there be no mistake if we
do not vote to override The veto today
the result will be devastating for all
of Coos County and others across this
entire State please join me in voting
yay to overturn this veto thank you J
Harrington thank you Mr Speaker uh this
is kind of like deja vu all over again
here we are back again with the third
and a never-ending series of bailout
bills for the Burgess biomass plant no
one's going to stand here and say it's
not a well-run efficient plant a
well-run plant it's not very efficient
because the thermal efficiency of the
plant is about 18% less than half of an
oil or coal or nuclear plant less than a
third of a combined cycle gas plant it's
just is not an efficient way to make
electricity but let's go back in history
just a little bit to see what happened
and how we got here the plant was
proposed back in the uh 2010 2012 region
and it had to go in front of the site
evaluation committee to get a permit I
was on that committee at the time now
they one of the things obviously a plant
like this has to do is raise Capital now
because of the uh federal laws uh and
under the Biden Administration Burgess
was able to get the production tax
credits paid UPF front they were able to
roll those up and get paid in advance
and use it towards Capital cost and they
also were eligible for what's called a
new market tax credit these amounted to
tens of millions of dollars from the
taxpayers that went to Burgess in the
form of of those breaks but that still
was not enough because there a these
plants are very expensive to build so
they had to get a purchase power
agreement without that they could not
get the capital to build their plant
they pursued actively pursued the
purchase power agreement with eversource
and they came to an agreement with
eversource this agreement went to the Pu
the Pu then modified it to put in what I
refer to as a safety valve basically it
said we'll we can pay you the terms of
the contract but if the amount being
paid continues to go over market rate to
the point where it comes over $100
million that the rate payers subsidize
Burgess for then Burgess will have to
start paying back the money that's
simply where we're at we've passed two
bailout bills in the past to put that
off we keep delaying it like they said
Kick the Can down the road and now they
want to change the contract
completely it's simple live up to the
contract that you signed no one forced
them to sign the contract if you sign a
contract for buying a house because you
think the value of the house is going to
go up over a period of time you take out
a loan and the value doesn't go up you
just can't go back to the bank and say
well you know I'm going only to make
half my mortgage pay payments because
the house didn't go up in value like I
expected it was and that's what they're
trying to do here another
misrepresentation that's often given is
somehow this is so important to the
electric grid in New Hampshire Burgess
accounts for about 0 2% of the capacity
in New England that's. 2% it's about 75
megawatt to put that in perspective with
of what's going on in the region next
spring ISO New England is going to allow
1,400 megawatts at the Mystic facility
to go out permanently they're going to
go away permanently it's 1400 megawatts
versus
75 so you look around and say who's
supporting this and who isn't well I can
tell you the business industry
Association is opposed to it the
environmental groups I believe with the
Siara Club as one of them is not
supporting it Don Cree the consumer
advocate of the State of New Hampshire
is not supporting it they all want the
veto to be
upheld so let's just look at what's
going on right now now right now
assuming that they run the bio purchas
bio plan is running they're going to get
paid rate payer subsidies of about
$44,000 an hour as we sit here so just
put that up we're here for a couple of
hours that's $8,000 in two hours that's
because the way the contract works every
source is required to pay them in the
range of $90 a megawatt hour for every
megawatt they produce and then ever so
immediately sells that power into the U
daily markets but the daily market price
right now is about $30 so the difference
is made up by that rate payer subsidy
when the cap that was in the contract
that they agreed to and signed was
reached which was the $100 million they
were supposed to start paying that back
and now they want to say no we want to
forget forgive that we don't want to
have to pay it back but we'll go back to
the terms of the contract once you wipe
out our debt and it'll continue to build
up but you know what's going to happen
next year two years from now three years
from now they right back here again
because they're still not going to be
able to pay it back because they're
still going to be getting massive
subsidies it we're just running up the
bill again this does nothing but delay
the inevitable this this plant may be
well-run and everything else but it's
just not an efficient way to make
electricity and they're going to
continue to run up that bill and the
rate payers are going to be responsible
so nothing's going to change
here they all we're doing is saying live
up to the terms of the contract that you
aggressively pursued and sign and
another little fact that I think most
people don't realize is that this is
only eversource customers that are
paying the subsidy if this plan is so
wonderful and so important to the state
then maybe should pass a tax would be a
more Equitable way and have everybody in
the state pay it but if you're a liberty
unitel or Co-op customer even if you're
a co-op customer who lives in the North
Country who makes their living off of
selling products to Berlin biomass you
don't pay a diam in subsidies but a
retired school teacher living in
Manchester on a fixed income pays a
higher electric bill to support this so
I guess it comes down to this does you
think the government should be picking
winners and losers and decide which
companies will be successful because of
subsidies or do you think people should
be free to make the choice of what type
of electricity they want to buy please
vote to uphold The
cascaden thank you Mr Speaker
I have notes so I can give you the facts
the Burgess biomass plant has produced
power for New Hampshire consistently and
reliably to the terms of the purchase
power agreement to the ter uh for 10
years now we midpoint during that 10year
period Burgess has contributed
$700
million to New Hampshire's
economy we made the right decision this
winter when we overwhelmingly passed the
house bill
142 there's been a lot of misinformation
about the management of this plant
recently yet there is no credible
evidence that this is anything but a
best-in-class management
team Burgess achieves availability and
credibility percentages of over
90% when the industry average is
58% they're a major partner in New
Hampshire's Forest products industry
and they support good jobs in the
industry their impact on the North
Country economy is huge and their
presence is felt throughout the region
and throughout the state locally burges
pay
16% of Berlin's property taxes provides
40% of the Berlin Waterworks
Revenue it will raise local and County
taxes in North Country communities
particularly coos if we let this veto
stand more facts true facts Burgess buys
800,000 tons of lowgrade wood per year
from
communities in all 10 counties of New
Hampshire the facility uses onethird of
all the wood cut in New Hampshire's
1.4 billion dollars of forest products
industry while providing steady
well-paying jobs to 29 plant employees
and supporting 240 jobs
Statewide so Burgess by itself injects
nearly $70 million into New Hampshire's
economy each year the economics of
managing our Timberlands will be upended
if we allow this plant to close we stand
to lose these and many more economic
benefits if we allow allow burges to
cease
operating to lose our one remaining
biomass plant particularly a plant that
is among the top three top three most
efficient and well-run biomass
facilities in the
country would be a real failure by this
legislature that failure would be a
caving into politics at a time our
fellow citizens looked us for help with
New Hampshire's economy
in hearings our constituents have asked
us to save New Hampshire's Forest
economy and also to help continue the
city of Berlin's economic recovery from
the previous Mill
shutdown overturning this video is the
right
decision to deliver economic benefits
for the North country and for the entire
State I am a Berlin
native I have a 40 plus career in the
entire northern region
I experienced the demise of the Pulp and
Paper
industry my family owned a business that
serviced the logging industry and I've
been on the personal and professional
downside of the city's declining
economy when the legislature voted
overwhelmingly in favor of 142 this
spring we got it right the reasons this
bill passed originally are just as valid
now as they were a few months ago let's
show the people who elected us our
Foresters our land owners our fellow
citizens that we can do the right thing
for New Hampshire and overturn the
governor's veto of House Bill
you the state constitution requires a
roll call or 2/3 vote is required to
overwrite a veto this will be a roll
seats
clear
house will be house will be in
order this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Summers for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
Burgess biomass plant to date has
already received over $200 million in
bailouts and if I know the HB 142 is for
all tents and purposes a bailout of
upwards of 70 million or more and if I
know that in two years a request for
another 70 million plus bailout will be
made and if I know $70
million every two years is quite
expensive for 30 plus
employees and if I know that the states
like Massachusetts and Massachusetts
current law and environmental groups no
longer view burning biomass as renewable
energy and if I generally believe that
just like Wall Street banks no one is
too big or too small to
fail then I would push the red button to
concur with the governor's veto thank
you Mr Speaker J I recognize
representative McGee for parlamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if if I know that letting this
veto stand forces a huge unjustified tax
increase on the people of the North
country and brings job losses and
uncertainty and if I know that this
plant receives no other rate payer money
than what appears in the signed contract
it entered into into 2013 and that
renewable energy credits do not count as
subsidies because they belong to the
energy taker which in this case is urce
not the the plant the
producer and if I know that Burgess
biomass is the last instate plant buying
New Hampshire's essential Timber
Products and that upending the
Timberland economics chokes local
economies shrinks our energy and
dependence and leaves New Hampshire more
vulnerable to forest fires and finally
if I know the North country is saying
enough is enough they came to us for
help and we gave it to them by a veto
proof vote
and they are still counting on us to see
it through their eyes then would I now
press the green button to put an end to
this outof step
veto thank you this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor of having the bill
become law you will press the green
button if you are opposed and wish to
sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
oh you didn't check in that's why your
[Music]
wheeler
all members president had an opportunity
to
vote 194 voting yay 159 voting nay it
fails to reach the 2/3 the governor's
veto is sustained for what reason is a
member rise I move that the remarks from
the previous debate be placed in the
objection the house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
337 relative to directing the Office
Professional lure and certification to
provide notice of public meetings and an
opportunity for comment from the public
and creating a new attorney to position
the question before the house is not
withstanding and govern's veto shall the
law chair recognizes representative
Carol
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker
most of you probably don't remember
House Bill 337 at
all that's because when it went to
Edna there was no opposition some
concerns so we had several subcommittee
meetings and amended the bill to fix
some of the concerns that were brought
to our attention it passed the house it
passed the committee unanimously and it
passed the house on
consent it went to finance cuz there's a
small cost involved in implementing
it they reviewed it passed it
unanimously in committee and it passed
the house on a
387 to0 roll call vote so House Bill 337
is the house
position in the Senate the office of
professional liur and
certification brought some additional
concerns and worked with the Senate to
put in language that settled their
concerns it passed the Senate on a Voice
vote
twice we concurred with the Senate
Amendment also on a Voice vote without
debate so this is a not minor build not
really very
controversial what it does is it
requires notice of meetings for
licensing
boards and that the information that the
board has be shared with the the
audience we've all been in various
boards or committee meetings where the
committee has a piece of paper with an
amendment or a schedule or a change and
they're all looking at it and discussing
it and a room full of people are staring
at them because that information is not
available to them there's nothing like
getting a 35 page Amendment you know
when you walk into the committee room
you're not going to have a chance to
review it
so what this bill does is it enforces
transparency for licensing
boards the governor did have a very good
point that it doesn't that it only
applies specifically to licensing boards
there's two reasons for that the first
is that they have a long history
of lack of
transparency and the licensed
individuals have been complaining to the
legislature for at least the 15 years
I've been here I mean possibly before I
wouldn't be surprised but there are
issues with various boards not sharing
information not announcing their
meetings and not being as transparent as
we want the government to
be so that's a good place to start the
other reason to do it is that it's a
relatively self-contained group we can
Implement these changes at the
oplc see how they work and if
it does turn out to encourage the best
practices that some organizations use
we'd implement it through throughout all
the boards and committees and other
groups in the
state but we'll we'll try it in the
licensing boards give it a fair shake
and then see if we can expand it
everything so I'm going to vote against
you state constitution requires a roll
call 2/3 vote is required to overwrite a
veto this will be a roll call vote
[Music]
seats
oh
this will be a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Merchant for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I believe government
transparency is essential to a
government of the
people and if I know board meetings are
posted by the Office Professional lenser
and certification oplc at least 30 days
before a board meeting and if I know a
board May hold an emergency meeting at
any time and if I know the board chair
has the discretion to alter the board of
agenda and to make late documents
available to the public at the
meeting what I now vote to override The
veto of House Bill 337 by pushing the
green
button the state constitution requires a
roll call if you're in favor of having
the bill become law you will press the
green button if you are opposed and wish
to sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
representative
burrow all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
251 voting yay 104 voting nay it does
receive the necessary 2/3 to override
veto the house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
342 relative to lead testing in
children the question before the house
is notwithstanding the governor's VTO
Weber thank you Mr
Speaker this was a fairly simple bill it
simply requires when a child enters
daycare or school for a form to be
filled out stating whether they have had
l
testing
previously we have a law that requires
that we have exceptions in the current
law but the problem that this bill was
intended to address is that compliance
has fallen off and we all know of the
potential damages of lead poisoning in
young children so the bill as it was
passed by the house in the Senate merely
provides another time and opportunity
for parents to be given
information if they have not had their
child tested about the law and about
testing
availability there is no barrier to
school entry in the bill that is all
still left to parents it is just a
further
opportunity to get this done so with
that I hope you will join me in
observing lead poison in Prevention Week
by passing this Bill thank
you the state constitution requires a
roll call a 2/3 vote is required to
override a veto this will be a roll call
[Music]
seats
clear
this will be a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative Lon for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that New Hampshire children are required
to have their blood levels tested at the
ages of 1 and two because it needs to be
done early in order to have appropriate
medical intervention and if I know that
many children and child care care well
before one year of age and that no child
enters school at the age of 2 years old
and most importantly Mr Speaker if I
know that the recent low Le testing
level numbers weren't because parents
weren't testing their children by choice
but because they couldn't because the
machines had been recalled but now that
recall has been addressed would I then
press the red button to sustain the
governor's
veto J recognize representative weather
Weber for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the bill is past prevents
no barriers to school entrance or
daycare entrance but merely another
opportunity to remind parents of the
dangers of lead poisoning and the
ability to Avail themselves when they
may not have during the time that the
machines were not available
would I now celebrate lead poisoning
Prevention Week by pressing the green
you the state constitution requires a
roll call a two3 voter is required to
override a veto if you're in favor of
having the bill become law you will
press the green button if you oppose and
wish to sustain the governor's veto you
will press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to sayate to
the
vote 184 voting a 171 voting a The veto
was
sustained representative osbor and
Wilhelm moved the adoption of an
amendment to house rules as proposed by
the rules committee and as printed in
the house
calendar
are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is
adopted representative Osburn and wilham
move the adoption of floor amendment to
house rule
66 in your seat pockets it's it's in
pockets
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted cler for I recognize the
clerk for Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate has voted to sustain the
governor's veto on the following bill
Senate Bill 42 relative to overpayment
of unemploy woming
compensation the Senate has voted to
sustain the governor's veto on the
following bill Senate Bill 51 creating a
commission to study charitable gaming
and historical horse races in relative
to the moratorium on licensed historical
horse racing
facilities the Senate has voted to
sustain the governor's veto on the
following bill Senate Bill 79 relative
to the participation of customer
generators in net energy metering the
Senate has voted to sustain the
governor's veto on the following bill
Senate Bill 193 relative to the
obligation of collective bargaining
units to negotiate in good faith and the
Senate has voted to sustain the
governor's veto the following bill
Senate Bill 256 establishing a safety
vehicles the the chair recognizes the
member from Auburn presentive Osborne
session the question is on the motion to
adjourn from the early session are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
I we have a few
announcements uh chair recognize
representative
Barry
thank you Mr Speaker uh this morning the
special committee on Child Care met we
took a very nice unanimous vote
unfortunately due to some confusion and
its placement in the calendar and being
properly noticed we get to meet again
and do the same vote again so if you are
a member of the House special committee
on childcare the moment we are adjourned
from this we will meet in room 206 to do
you how the chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker a couple of quick
announcements uh one please check your
mailboxes today and empty them uh we
have several uh packages that have been
delivered also um your blackbooks are in
your boxes uh also there will be a lunch
served outside uh hosted by the
conquered Lions Club after the
adjournment of this session Kanas kowas
club I'm
minutes
chair this is unanimous consense please
be attentive chair recognize
representative
Bay thank you Mr Speaker um my fellow
Representatives I'm lose Bay I'm a
representative from
do you may or may not know know um that
I'm a three-time breast cancer
survivor and October is a breast cancer
awareness
month and um this should be a reminder
uh for
us to get our breast cancer screening or
to remind our loved ones to get our
screening in
um 198 8 when uh 1998 when I was 32
years old I was diagnosed for the first
time I was about to get
married I was moving cross country from
Iowa to New Hampshire I was changing
jobs I was um selling my home buying a
new home so and I was diagnosed with
breast cancer and um get my first
treatment within the six week
period so I can say that over a six week
period I
experienced the most stressful things
that happens in one's
life now I always want to remind people
about the uh breast cancer awareness
because early detection is
key and I also want to show myself as an
example
that um one can
Thrive and live
Cloud um between my first and second um
breast cancer diagnosis I had two
wonderful
children
um and after between my second and third
[Applause]
marathon I have now rent 25
marathons more importantly it's after my
third breast cancer diagnosis that I was
[Applause]
office within the last few weeks my very
best friend at work was diagnosed with
breast
cancer and on the same
week one of my sisters was diagnosed
cancer
me
and uh they're both uh going through
their
treatments uh they're both in um good
spirits but this is just something that
I when I was first diagnosed I did you
know it was all about
me and now that I have learned to live
and Thrive with it it's not about me
anymore it's about the rest of
us I have um tried to uh my every
opportunity uh to speak with those that
um need help and guidance so if you know
someone I'm
available I have um raised over $30,000
for cancer
research but with all of that it really
depends on each and every one of us and
so um as uh to celebrate the breast
cancer awareness month thank you to
those who actually wore pink today um
and uh there are still a few more days
in October wear your pink as I've been
wearing pink for every day of this month
thank you thank you Mr
[Applause]
Speaker
for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I would uh ask that the
remarks on the observance of Breast
Cancer month and their inspirational
message be printed in the permanent
journal without objection chair
optimal thank you Mr Speaker I raise I
rise today on behalf of the Hillsboro
delegation to congratulate
representative Jen Morton on receiving
the spirit of New Hampshire award for
her contributions the awards were held
earlier this week and conquered
representative Morton has devoted her
time to assisting many organizations in
her community including the nsha pride
the Nashua soup kitchen and shelter the
peacock players which is a children's
theater group and maybe the biggest one
of all end 68 hours of hunger the
organization which collect and
distributes food to food insecure
student students in the n greater
nashille area so that they don't go
hungry over the weekend on behalf of the
naswa delegation and those in the
greater nashwa area who benefit from the
organizations that Jen works with we
extend our deepest thanks and
congratulations Jen will you stand
[Applause]
up
kushman thank you Mr Speaker for
recognizing me thank you uh fellow
legislators uh everyone in this chamber
swore an oath to uphold the New
Hampshire New Hampshire State con new
hampster New Hampshire state
constitution in part one the people
reserve for themselves certain rights
that government shall make no laws to
violate all laws Republic repugnant to
the Constitution are null and void we've
all heard
that the Supreme Court recently has said
that the historical analysis method is
to be used to determine the intent of
the law or the
Constitution this means that what the
usages and customs of the time the law
or Constitution was written determines
how that law applied
Today part one article two of the New
Hampshire state constitution says the
people have a right to give instructions
to their
representatives Webster's Dictionary of
the American English language of
1828 defines instruct as to give notice
and also to impart knowledge or educate
and also to direct or command to furnish
with
orders article 38 of part one says quote
the people they have a right to require
of their lawgivers and magistrate an
exact and constant observance of the
fundamental principles of the
Constitution Article 8 of part one says
all power residing originally in and
being derived from the people all the
magistrates and officers of government
are their substitutes and agents and at
all times accountable to
them some have said that well being
being accountable means every 2 years
the people have an election and they
vote on us by um they vote on us and
expect us to hold our campaign promises
hold to them I don't find that concept
anywhere in writing in the Constitution
or the actual law and I don't see how
that squares with part one article 8
that says agents are accountable at all
times nor part one article 38 that says
EX exact and
constant in reality the people have the
right to instruct us as their agents
when it comes to protecting their
constitutional rights that's our primary
job they have the right to provide us
notice of a violation of their rights
that we swore to protect and to instruct
Us in remedying those violations in so
far as it's within our Authority that
they granted to us in the constitution
in part
two they can't tell us to stand on our
heads but they can provide us notice
that a state agency is violating rights
and is in need of
Correction they can instruct us to take
action to rectify the situation with the
powers that we have been given by them
the people have a right to constant
observance of the law by their
magistrates and when constitutional
rights are violated we magistrates have
a duty under our oath to assist and make
it
right if we ignore please for help and
continue to let people's rights be viol
ated if later they do take it to court
and it's found their rights were
violated and we knew and did nothing we
were given notice and said I don't have
to do what you say and didn't give any
evidence to that fact if we can't show
that we don't have to then we become
culpable we violated our oath and now
we're a part of denying the people their
rights we were derelict in our duty and
that is maladministration
and with notice it can rise to the level
of
malice we can be held accountable and
notices have been used in court to prove
that a defendant has no plausible
deniability so let's get back to the
basics of our true purpose here in this
body the the securing of the
Constitutional inalienable rights of the
people thank
[Applause]
you
representative Osman moves a house
standard recess for the purpose
Sor for what reason does member rise I'd
like to uh request that the previous
remarks be put in the permanent
journal without
objection for what reason is a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I move the
remarks of our colleague from Nashville
also be placed in the permanent journal
without
objection representative Z moves at Host
stand and recess for the purpose of
receiving messages after which business
is concluded and the house shall stand
adjourned from the 2023 session are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all is in posos nay you
eyes have it the house stand adjourned
session